à quoi va ressembler le québec en 2066
ça doit pas facile de trouver une
réponse
compte tenu de tous les changements
qu'on voit chaque année au niveau
politique et tout mais l'institut de la
statistique du québec donne quelques
pistes avec des projections dévoilé ce
matin chantal girard démographe
justement à l'institut bodjona d'objets
rares alors on peut affirmer une chose
on sera plus nombreux au québec dans 50
ans effectivement si les tendances
démographiques se maintiennent la
population du québec a augmenté elle
devrait continuer d'augmenter les
continuer d'augmenter de plus en plus
lentement donc il ya peu près à 8,4
millions d'habitants au québec
actuellement on pourrait passer à 9
millions autour de 2030 et à presque 10
millions autour de 2000 66 qui était la
limite de notre projection bon quand tu
du vieillissement de la population
ça fait longtemps que les démographes
parle du vieillissement de la population
là c'est sûr qu'on entre dans une phase
où il va augmenter de manière assez
importante on parle beaucoup des
générations nombreuses du baby-boom on
situe en général qu'elles sont nés en
1946 et 1966 donc elles ont commencé à
franchir le cap des 65 ans et plus et
les plus gros scores devons s'apprêter à
franchir ce seuil de aussi au cours des
prochaines années donc là là sur le 1.7
millions de plus au québec qu'on pourra
être en 1066 ces deux groupes des 65 ans
et plus qui pourraient lui augmenté de 1
point 3 millions donc c'est une
augmentation importante en termes de
proportion est à peu près de 18% de la
population qui a 65 ans et plus
actuellement
ça pourrait être au tour de ceux de 28%
au tour de 2065 ceux qui trouvent que le
groupe power est un peu trop présents et
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
qu'est ce qu'il en est de l'espérance de
vie
l'espérance de vie
dans c'est évidemment une projection
qu'on fait mais dans l'hypothèse que
qu'on faisait que continué d'augmenter
mais de plus en plus lentement pour les
prochaines années et se rapprocher de 90
ont un peu moins de 90 ans autour de
2000 66 bon ou va-t-on vivre à la ville
ou à la campagne
de plus en plus à la ville il faut
croire parce que effectivement les
régions où la croissance est la plus
importante c'est les régions autour de
montréal laval et laurentides par
exemple pourrait connaître une
croissance d'à peu près 22 % de leur
population ça c'est à l'horizon 2040 et
nos projections régionales sont autour
de 2040 et les régions pour lesquelles
c'est le plus difficile c'est les
régions de l'est du québec la région de
la corne d'or pourrait voir sa
population diminuer de 15%
gaspésie-îles-de-la-madeleine peut-être
de 9% bas-saint-laurent et
saguenay-lac-saint-jean peut-être de 6%
donc c'est les quatre régions pour
lesquelles le déclin de la population
pourrait être important etes-vous mesure
de faire un portrait ou dévaluer dossier
de l'immigration parce que ça peut
changer aux quatre ans quelquefois les
politiques avec les différents
gouvernements alors qu'est ce que vous
voyez quelque chose dans vos projections
en fait nous on ne fait une hypothèse
ça a effectivement été une hypothèse qui
n'a pas été simple à réaliser
mais on a examiné les tendances du passé
on a examiné les avis d'experts on a
examiné ce qui se passait à l'échelle du
du canada donc dans notre hypothèse
d'immigration on a suivi les ce qui est
annoncé pour les prochaines années pour
les premières années puis ensuite on a
fait une hypothèse d'immigration qui est
autour de 50 5000 immigrants par année
ça ressemble à ça ressemble au plus haut
niveau qui ont été qui ont été observés
donc d'ici 2026 bien aux ans et ses
niveaux lol ça représente de mémoire
peut-être 16% de l'immigration
canadienne c'est ce qu'on a mis dans
l'eau dans nos hypothèses puisque sauf
que dans ce groupe là sont au jeu se
fait sur la population des 20-64 ans
surtout mais aussi chez les plus chez
les plus jeunes puisque ensuite les la
population immigrante va avoir des va
avoir des enfants ici donc c'est celle
le rôle qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent jouer
dans la situation démographique
bon ben écoutez on a un premier coup
d'oeil corse comme ça merci beaucoup
d'être venu nous en parler tout au cours
de journée j'ai l'impression que ça va
être exploité chacun de ces volets de
ces statistiques sur le québec merci
beaucoup
ça m'a fait plaisir à voir